Dear students, welcome to the class.
Today's class is going to explain
Support vector machine,
Sport vector machine, which we call as SEM
First of all, you have basic introduction.
There are many terms in it.
First, it needs time.
Don't hesitate to direct it on numerical.
Sometimes, in any topic, whenever we talk about machine learning
Sometimes, we feel that we do direct numerical
and then we will understand that thing.
First, you need time.
When it comes to how to do SEM,
and where to use it.
First of all, what is SEM?
This supervised machine learning algorithm.
This is not supervised.
It is supervised, where we provide labelled data.
And this classification and regression
are the work of both.
You can also do classify and use both of the tasks of regression.
If I talk about the point of classification,
then what we need to do?
We have done a linear separable
I have done two types of data.
E-mail is spam or e-mail is not spam.
If I am doing a linear separable
through straight line, I can easily classify it.
But here, we have to explain the terminology first.
What are the terms?
The first term is hyperplane.
Very important, the story of your start of SEM.
What is hyperplane?
hyperplane is a decision boundary
that separates the data point of different classes in the feature space.
I mean, here, let's suppose,
I have two dimensions of data.
And let's suppose, I have some data.
Let's suppose, how can I take a star form
in the multiplication form?
I have some data points,
which are in the star form.
Let's suppose, we have some data points
in the form of minus.
In this way, we have two data sets.
I have some values.
What I have done now?
I have found a straight line here on hyperplane.
That is, it is separating easily
two points.
I have an example of e-mail spam and not spam.
I have separated the spam from this way
and I have separated the spam from the nodes.
I have defined two classes in the data.
I have defined two classes.
Positive class, negative class like that.
So, here, the straight line is classified.
It is what a kind of hyperplane.
So, what can I say about this line?
This is my hyperplane.
So, this decision boundary is a decision boundary.
This is a boundary.
I mean, let's suppose, it is a node spam.
It is a little bit of a space.
You can say something about an example.
If you have a point, let's suppose,
some point, and it is here.
So, you can say, it is in this class.
Because all these things are separated from this way.
Okay?
So, you can understand it in this way.
Now, let's suppose, if there is another point,
it is below.
So, you can understand that it is also allowing it from below.
So, this is your simple concept.
Let's suppose, I will talk about it next.
What is next?
I have a cone.
I have understood the hyperplane.
So, I have understood it.
The hyperplane, you can see here,
mathematical representation, if we talk about it.
What is the straight line?
We have already done it.
Mx plus b.
Here, wx plus b, we call it as the base.
What is w?
Our weight.
Wait.
You can say, that my x feature is.
The input feature is.
It has a corresponding weight.
What is w?
So, if it is multiple, then it will be multiple weights.
As if it is w, let's suppose, it is the x1.
It is the x2 of the w2.
And finally, what is b?
You know the top of the bias.
This is the straight line.
So, that is your bias.
And this weight and this will be your features.
Let's suppose, I will talk about the example.
If I want to classify,
that you have given some data,
you have done it by working on it.
Then you have to check.
That the cat will come in class.
This is dog.
So, cat will come in class.
I have added the cat in class.
Dog will come in class.
So, based on the weighted and the base.
So, here I have two features.
One is the weight and the other is the height.
So, my hyperplane could be water.
3 into weight plus 2 into height minus 50.
This is the way you have training.
This is the equation.
Take the example.
So, here w1 is the weight.
And this weight is the weight of its corresponding weight.
The three.
Whatever you have given, you have to multiply it from three.
So, you have to multiply it from three.
The height of its corresponding weight is 2.
And what is minus 50?
Why is it minus 50?
So, this equation represents your three.
Which you divide easily by your class.
Now, here, the second thing is that
Support vectors.
Let's suppose, margin.
What is margin?
Margin is the distance between hyperplane
and the nearest data point of either class.
What is the margin?
Margin is the distance between the hyperplane
and the nearest data point of either class.
What does it mean?
We have understood hyperplane.
The two classifies it.
The two classifies it easily.
It is working like a boundary.
Or, go there or there.
Like that.
But, what is margin?
What is margin?
That this is my greatest data point.
Let's suppose, this is the plus value of my class.
The positive value of my class.
The data point of hyperplane is the same.
I have crossed the line of my class.
In this negative class,
I have a straight line of my class.
It means, in hyperplane,
I have a marginal line of my class.
And the marginal line of my class
is the nearest data point of hyperplane.
Like this nearest data point,
it will cross the line.
One can be multiple.
Like here, this is my 1 and this is my 2.
Let's suppose, this is my nearest data point.
So, the margin line is cross the line of these two.
So, in one way, this margin line of my class
is the positive value of my class.
This margin line of my class is the hyperplane's parallel.
So, here, I have to take the margin of this way.
That my class is the separate data point of this value.
So, between the hyperplane and the nearest data point,
what is your margin?
And as we try to maximize this margin,
if you want to ask me in theory,
I want to maximize the margin or minimize it.
So, obviously, you can see that
if I suppose, this way, there is a data set.
And let's suppose, take a data set.
And in that, your margin line is going this way.
And this is your let's suppose hyperplane.
And in this way, you have another negative value.
Take the second class.
And there, your data point is going this way.
And a margin line is going this way.
So, look, here, the margin is less than the distance between them.
So, what we want is that, between the distance between my hyperplane and the distance between the distance between them.
This is the greater the number of the difference.
Because, as much as we can separate these two classes,
we can easily separate them.
So, if I ask them, which one is better?
This one is better because, here,
the distance between the hyperplane and the margin is more comparatively.
So, that is why, we want to maximize this margin.
Then, and what is the sport vector?
What is the sport vector?
These data points are closest to the hyperplane.
And what are the points we say?
Support vector.
These points influence the orientation and position of the hyperplane.
So, these help us.
From one side, if I show you this here easily,
and this is the point, which is helping the margin line to draw the margin line,
the nearest data point of the hyperplane,
we say, support vectors.
This is the name of the group, which is called the number of the numbers.
Hard margin.
Hard margin is that, zoom that data is perfectly separable by the hyperplane.
All points are light outside the margin.
That means, if we are separating linearly,
I mean, if I divide the two classes here and here,
I divide them easily, then this is my one hand.
We can't separate linearly in the soft.
For example, my way is some star, star,
and some points.
And in the middle of that, let's suppose,
some points are like this, minus, minus, minus, minus, minus,
this way, some minus point is ahead.
So, here, I can't separate properly.
If I make a hyperplane like this,
then some of my classes are also overlapping in the other class.
So, this is my hard margin.
We want to do this, but we can't separate linearly.
So, if we want to do this,
we can't do this.
So, if we want to increase the dimension,
then we can do this in three dimensions.
If we want to do this in three dimensions,
then it becomes easier to separate linearly.
Or we can increase it in more dimension.
So, this is the kernel function.
So, there are various kernel function.
The kernel function is your simplest table.
Because it is linearly separable data.
When it is in that, it is not visible.
But if your linear separable is not in that,
then you are over-rapping it.
So, you are doing polynomial kernel,
radial basis function.
We can use this method.
We can use the two dimensions or three dimensions of the data
to increase the dimension.
And after increasing, we can easily separate them.
So, we use these things further.
So, here is only a basic theoretical introduction
that we should generalize the model of SVM
so that we can linearly separate it.
So, the more the margin is, the better it is.
And note all these points.
Then we will do an example of an example.
Which you will explain to us later.
Thank you.